oh
bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale alors ce
soir stéphane laborde n'est pas là déjà
on s'excuse pour l'émission qui n'a pas
eu lieu la semaine dernière
donc pour vous annoncer que stéphane est
en vacances pendant encore trois
semaines enfin pendant trois semaines en
tout donc il va bientôt rentrer il
revient fin février et ce soir pour
présenter l'émission j'ai avec moi
nicolas la vallée bonsoir nicolas
bonsoir et loire alors rappelons que tu
étais webmaster du site la tour
infernale et que tu viens d'être absorbé
cydia par le journal libération qui va
donc créer un priori un portail échec
tout à fait donc après avoir mené un bon
bout de chemin avec la tour infernale
donc étant le webmestre depuis
maintenant plus d'un an et demi et bien
le site intéresser un grand groupe comme
libération est effectivement très bonne
nouvelle pour pour le noble jeu
libération se lance et compte investir
pas mal donc sur sur le jeu d'échecs au
travers d'un portail qui va s'appeler
sport échec alors on rappelle que le
journal libération effectivement est le
seul journal francophone à avoir un
bruit quotidienne donc ils font déjà des
efforts pour les échecs des attenant
apparemment il ça s'amplifie tout à fait
donc c'est vrai que tu as fait vrai que
libération une forte légitimité sur le
jeu jean pierre mercier a quand même
aujourd'hui dix ans de métier derrière
ça se disant je vous rappel c'est comme
le journaliste qui écrit la chronique
quotidienne dans libération et depuis
dix ans oui depuis dix ans donc c'est
une très très bonne nouvelle pour pour
le jeu que bien de voir un acteur et un
média tels que le journal libération qui
se lancent qui se lance sur ce créneau
là donc beaucoup de surprises version
première version du site attendue début
mars mi mars
donc on aura l'occasion d'en discuter je
viendrai si tu le veux bien présenté en
avant première les fonctionnalités du
site et voilà donc c'est génial
d'accord en gros deux trois mots durs à
quoi sur ce site alors la version 1 sera
une version quand même modeste on peut
faire des articles produite par des
journalistes donc des articles de
qualité de grande qualité on aura le
problème quotidien donc de jean-pierre
on aura un forum modéré on aura les
tournois par e-mail tels qu'on les
connaissait sur la tour infernale avec
une bière sont plus sécurisés
beaucoup mieux et et puis quelques
surprises qui viendront en surprises
attendues voilà le site échec de
libération donc fait par nicolas vallée
qui est avec nous ce soir
l'actualité est évidemment on va la
rattraper puisque il ya peu une
démission la semaine dernière donc la
grosse grosse actualité c'est comme la
fin de ce tournoi chorus de vivendi
alors nicolas l'enjeu de ce tournoi a
priori c'était un petit peu de savoir
qui est le meilleur joueur du monde
alors je sais pas comment on a ressenti
ça sur enfin chez libé ou à la tour
infernale
c'est vrai que après le match brillant
games qui a retenu énormément
d'attention
il ya un petit creux et puis puis là le
championnat du monde ensuite fidea
nombre de champions du monde et là le
choc
kasparov anand cramique les trois
meilleurs joueurs au monde qui se
rencontrent et donc effectivement on
attendait beaucoup beaucoup de ce
tournoi et je pense que les attentes ont
été récompensés parce que aujourd'hui
kasparov revient après sa défaite contre
cramique kasparov l'emportent avec 9
points sur 13 et 1/2 deux points
d'avancé sur le second
il est premier de week-ends ou alors
effectivement direct sport fait premier
c'est une chose dont il restait trois
rondes a commenté on va vous les
commenter bien entendu le classement
final c'est kasparov 1er 2e nicolas
c'est à nantes et 3e cramique donc notre
tiercé de tête quand même c'est quand
même les trois plus forts joueurs du
monde tout ça ça se tient kasparov 9.1
enduite ennemis krainik 8
bref ils sont tous là donc a priori est
ce qu'on peut dire que ça départage je
ne sais pas bien je pense que si on
regarde un peu le jeu on aura l'occasion
de commenter les derniers roues mais
c'est vrai que un tournoi tel que
celui-là favorise en général les les
heures qui sont très offensifs kasparov
c'est quelqu'un qui quand même ils
lancent tout même s'il a les noirs on a
des joueurs qui sont beaucoup plus
passifs écrit qu'avec les noirs comme
travnik jour très très solide et puis on
essaye de blindés quesnoy et puis de
prendre le point avec les blancs
kasparov lui c'est vraiment un jeu sont
compromis et comme en plus il a la
classe et la force derrière
eh bien ça fait souvent la différence
dans ce genre de tournoi donc on s'en
tamponne de garry kasparov où je suis je
suis admiratif effectivement de garry
kasparov mais également de la dynamique
et de filles seins atteindra non je n'ai
pas vraiment de préférence je constate
simplement que en tournoi dans les
tournois de ce genre kasparov souvent et
dominateur alors les trois dernières
parties donc on vous avait quitté
kasparov était en avance il avait à
nantes qui était assez loin dans le
classement et donc qu'est ce qui s'est
passé garry kasparov lui donc gagne une
partie contre timan et ensuite en chêne
nul contrebande velits et contre michael
adams
donc il finit avec deux points sur trois
c'est pas mal ça lui assurer la première
place on guérit kasparov en fait à un
peu levé le pied dans cette fin de
tournoi la grosse surprise donc laurent
frayssinet qui est avec nous donc dans
l'émission on a parlé du candidat
spéciale avec les reportages des
interviews et tous nous avait dit je
sens bien à nantes terminé deuxième dans
ce tournoi ce n'était pas facile au
moment où il a dit effectivement un
monde a fini par trois victoires
consécutives ce qu'il a parachuté à la
deuxième place donc laurent frayssinet à
des dons de médium
je crois qu'on peut le dire alors un an
d'effectivement termine très très fort
le tournoi un petit bémol quand même à
ce résultat puisque c'est
en fait il a rencontré les plus faibles
entre guillemets du tournoi à la fin
donc ils terminent très très fort j'ai
un grand regret quand même parce que
j'ai l'impression qu'elle n'a pas tout
donné dans ce tournoi il a fait
énormément de nuls en début contre les
forts joueurs
il n'a pas joué vraiment content garry
kasparov
on attendait un kasparov revanchard eh
bien pas du tout en fait c'est un hand
avec les noirs qui prend en fait la
position de force et kasparov s'en sort
de justesse
oui effectivement ça vous l'avez déjà
commenté c'était cette fameuse
espagnoles vis manhattan on a été bon
enfin kasparov on voulait quand même
mais bon il n'a rien pu faire un nom
d'allah trop serré du début est donc en
fait je reste quand même un peu sur un
sentiment de faim par rapport à ça parce
que j'ai l'impression qu'à nantes avait
vraiment tout pour gagner ce tournoi il
avait tout pour yesornow ont fait en
tout cas si on dit qu'il a joué il assis
là pas été très percutant pas très
motivée et puisqu'il vient d'être
champion du monde d'affilée il termine
quand même deuxième devant donc tout un
tas de très bons joueurs et un demi
point seulement de kasparov independent
kasparov qui lui jouer un petit peu son
sa réputation dans ce tournoi faut bien
le dire puisque il avait plus rien gagné
depuis qu'il a perdu contre kramnik donc
ils étaient très motivés dont canon
d'effectivement gâte bas les trois plus
faibles et trois hollandais donc enfin
trois parmi les plus faibles
il va vendre hellip icade timan
effectivement c'est bon c'est comme ça
vladimir kramnik lui termine avec donc
il s'est pris une défaite contre
morozevich cinq mondes avant la fin et
ensuite il a terminé avec deux petites
nul
iba shirov pas mal puisque je suis en
fait est très en forme de petit nul pour
finir à 8
voilà pour venir à munich et la grosse
déception nicolas pour les fans c'est
alex hayes shirov qui termine avec
seulement un sur cinq
alors qu'ils avaient dominé le tournoi
de du début à la fin
ah oui c'est vrai qu'on s'attend on
attendait beaucoup shirov mais
malheureusement j'ai presque envie de
dire ça commence à devenir une habitude
dans le sens où chirac démarre toujours
très très fort très motivés puis se
passe quelque chose en fin de tournoi
bon là c'est un peu exceptionnel et
rencontrer les plus forts mais
d'habitude il se passe un truc à vouloir
gagner trop il craque et puis après
c'est après c'est ça chante ça
s'enchaîne
on avait déjà connu ce scénario à
sarajevo l'année dernière donc
effectivement l'excelsior tu n'as pas
les nerfs suffisamment solide ou en tout
cas ne tient pas la distance
pour finir survie ce qu'en dit on à une
dernière interview qu'on vous a pas
montré c'est celle de mirego revitch
alors on va vous la montrer et ça nous
permettra de diriger un peu sur le
tournoi b puisqu'à de temps là bas donc
voilà tout de suite mis hajrovic napias
news world présence of mist mais cargo
revello my so simply où ils devaient
supporter nov
agde et 3e rencontre des côtes des
continents scholes in french hewitt car
au final c'est fantastique réseau match
grey's anatomy blé goude de new york
lundi
tout 9 h 15 leading probable
inextinguible avis super content
can you and live résultats exemple of
garry kasparov au but she loves you up
garé many years ago sohou dreamworks et
assoit sa meilleure seconde la sortie
des boîtes connaissez by the winner of
thorns hamad bin khalifa reste au groupe
à tous next year basse terre garry
kasparov de gré à gré tout rires
il narre si will play veut un hymne inc
and our spécialistes spécialistes of
quick games au saut
you want is you waiting for this event
notre libraire barnes noble art of the
next 2 you go for chronic ce titre sognu
scalp à l'autre et good luck
voilà mirail gourévitch commentée par le
sympathique jean luc chavanon alors bon
le broc présente rapidement il a été
troisième joueur mondial ya une dizaine
d'années entraîneur de carrie kasparov
l'aï joué le tournoi b petite récession
il a gagné ce tournoi
il s'est donc qualifiée pour le prochain
big ben dit donc mail tournament qu'est
ce qu'il a dit là dit garry kasparov
était très fort et est toujours très
fort ça effectivement on s'en doute est
donc voilà un gourévitch très en forme
qui jouera nicolas la coupe du monde
deux parties rapides à canach
affectivement donc
on attend beaucoup plus justement il
veut se faire kasparov et karpov donc
ils étaient entre de l'attraper les
scalps 17 ex ou champion du monde dont
il a dit d'abord karpov ensuite kasparov
et ensuite chronique alors il a battu
karpov au cap d'agde le cap d'agde
ils espèrent battre kasparov à cannes et
crame dit quelques rames liquide 1 quand
il voudra et je pense qu'il a les moyens
d'y arriver liddell les magnans une
partie je pense que tout est jouable
en tous cas me rigaud à bitche fort
sympathique
donc voilà wisches kenzy bat terminons
terminaux là-dessus kasparov et gagner
et donc le challenge continue pour
savoir qui est le meilleur joueur du
monde oui d'autant plus qu'entre un
tournoi de cette envergure et puis un
match a toujours aussi sans de choses
vraiment différente
donc je pense qu'on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui kasparov et peut-être
bien le numéro un dans ce genre de
tournoi en partie fermée et bien il a
une revanche à prendre en un match fermé
ne revanche apprend tout à fait c'est la
deuxième année consécutive que garry
kasparov gagne le tournoi de vi choisit
donc espérons que ça dure ou que ça
s'arrête pour les fans de chacun des
partis alors nicolas je crois que
maintenant il ya une autre actualité
c'est l'actualité française
et oui le championnat de france par
équipe qui vient de débuter premier week
end alors tu a analysé ce week-end donc
est ce que tu peux nous en dire quelques
chose est tout à fait donc rappelons-le
nationale c'est celle de poules donc le
week-end dernier trois rondes se sont
disputés donc sur les échiquiers de la
nationale 1
donc je te propose de voir un petit peu
les résultats en détail avant de
avant de montrer le classement d'accord
on ne parlait dans le classement final
on va quand même rappeler puisque on
n'en avait jamais parlé dans diagonale
ou très peu qu'il s'agit d' équipes de
neuf joueurs donc c'est pas comme au
foot ils jouent ils sont pas neufs à
réfléchir en même temps nicolas il ya
neuf joueurs qui jouent individuellement
donc en fait c'est une équipe ii
composée d'individualités c'est à dire
qu'effectivement si kasparov et là il
n'a pas besoin de passer la balle il
joue sa partie s'ils gagnent on encaisse
le point donc effectivement le jeu par
équipe aux échecs c'est ça neuf joueurs
à la fin s'il y en a 5 à gagner qui en
gagne et ça fait un point de match
puisqu'on a gagné 5,4 sachant qu'une
victoire pour une équipe ramène trois
points
une nulle ramène deux points une défaite
ramène un point et zéro point c'est
repenser la défaite par forfait donc
c'est pas comme au foot on n'encourage
pas la victoire à tout prix c'est pas 3
1 0 c'est 3-2 or voilà chacun son truc
est donc bien c'est parti national 1
poule à la ronde
1 cappelle-la-grande contre noyon deux
équipes qui se tiennent d'ailleurs
résultat nul 2-2 second second choc
clichy gonfreville dans clichy c'est une
équipe qui est extraordinaire lui j'ai
émis lautier aux premiers échiquiers
igor nataf traiterait golfe
quelle équipe clichy c'est une superbe
équipe c'est donc ils sont champions de
france sortants
ils font partie des favoris bien entendu
cette année donc il ya joël lautier il
ya une armada de russes très fort enfin
il ya de très gros beauf qui a écrit
choo qui va jouer pour eux donc
igor nataf manuela pixels à olivier
rhône et qui sont les classiques
français
kosten donc pas kosten fdn conquest des
très bons angles est également non
clichy très forte équipe effectivement
est donc là deux matches très chaud très
chaud puisque joël lautier notre joël
nationale a rencontré viktor bologan et
joël a gagné viktor bologan quand même
qu'ils alignent 2684 lots rappelons que
viktor bologan avait une série de gains
consécutive en tournoi qui était de 3 ou
4 qui est vraiment impressionnant il a
gagné notamment au tournoi de vente
karpov
donc ça permet en fait cette nationale a
permis à jo le pied de s'illustrer en
battant un très fort ce soir
à noter quand même que je lautier est
également très fort notons également
igor nataf deuxième échec et qui a perdu
contre contre myr algo revitch notre
belle ça méritait donc d'être souligné
alors troisième donc troisièmes
rencontres mulhouse contre bill villiers
jeu vidéo quand bischwiller et alors là
un score sans appel 7 1 pour mulhouse
royal originaire je crois qu'ils
viennent de monter c'est pas une très
grosse équipe c'est pas une très grosse
équipe
c'est vrai qu'en face il y avait quatre
j'ai émis il ya énormément de
différences lots d'une équipe à l'autre
donc un résultat logique mais certains
quand même c'est un résultat très très
dur alors nancy strasbourg 3-2 pour
nancy nancy qui est menée donc
par igor ken keen et christian bauer
pour les principalement par christian
bauer puisque nancy c'est l'équipe
enfin cette chouchou l'équipe chouchou
de christian bauer puisqu'il a appris à
jouer là bas
il reste avec eux il a raison donc c'est
une très bonne équipe avec des très bons
joueurs donc mon premier premier match
une victoire c'est bien pour eux alors
ronde de noyon contre gonfreville une
petite surprise donc
noyon gagne 3,2 de parts dans contre
gonfreville petite surprise au premier
chic et puisque mereiles gorée vite je
perds contre leonid goldstein effective
alors mihailovic c'est curieux il perd
pas souvent il est très solide mais bon
ça arrive
donc ça c'est les premiers échiquiers
puisque dans les matchs par équipe on
est les plus forts en haut du classement
et donc noyon qui n'alignait qu'un seul
grand maître contre trois grands maîtres
en face et bien créé donc une petite
surprise
cappelle la grande honte clichy 6 2
ports clichy normale normale et festive
mans clichy c'est quand même un rouleau
compresseur
même si à cappelle-la-grande ya
jean-marc degraeve qui je crois dans ce
match a battu igor nataf ça suffit pas
toujours
donc si do en fait les scores on
comptabilise pas les nuls voilà pourquoi
ça fait une somme qui n'est pas égal à 9
donc les trois premiers chéquier assez
des résultats assez assez partagé par
contre sur les derniers chantiers il n'y
a pas eu photo
clichy a remporté tous les duels mais
c'est souvent ce qui se passe c'est à
dire que les équipes pas très forte
prennent quelques ténors sur les
premiers sites et quelques grands
maîtres mais ensuite d'effectivement ils
n'ont pas les moyens d'aller jusqu'au
bout de leurs neuf échiquier et donc
c'est là que les grosses équipes les
grosses cylindrées marque répond donc
mulhouse strasbourg 4-1 mulhouse câline
quand même une moyenne de 200 points elo
de plus sur chacun des sites des
échiquiers pardon donc
un résultat assez impressionnant c'est
une très belle équipe également je crois
qu'il faut le faut souligner strasbourg
c'est pas mal mais c'est plutôt l'équipe
d'il ya 15 20 ans ils ont ils ont
multiples titres de champion de france
il ya des années c'est une équipe bis
avec les frères ross
effectivement c'est une équipe un peu
sur le retour donc nancy bij ville et
3,2 pour un con si donc on va peut-être
accéléré parce que si on détaille tous
les matches comme ça on va pas s'en
sortir l'école a alors eu accès on va
accélérer un peu dans contre donc que
les matches phares on est trois clichés
noyon 6 0 voilà ça c'est un match phare
noyon donc petite ville du nord de la
france qui a quand même une équipe en
nationale 1 il faut les saluer meybon fo
contre clichy c'est toujours pareil
c'est la taule ensuite nancy mulhouse
alors là tu score très serré puisque
mulhouse ne l'emportent que d'un point
contre nancy
c'est d'ailleurs la féminine qui fait
gagner qui fait gagner l'équipe mulhouse
ways bischwiller strasbourg 5 0 pour
strasbourg donc un résultat assez
impressionnant donc s'il y situe le bien
on va passer à la poule b donc ça
c'était le premier groupe on est divisés
en deux groupes de valeur à peu près
équivalente donc il ya des et ensuite on
prend les quatre premiers de chaque
groupe et on les fait jouer dans la
poule finale alors deuxième donc poule
montpellier contre drancy 5 1 pour
montpellier montpellier bonne équipe ils
font partie des favoris pour évidemment
de cette poule peut-être pour le
championnat ils sont un peu léger mais
il allie notamment laurent frayssinet
dans l'eure dans leur équipe ce qui est
pas mal et si grand maître est si grand
maître auxerre bordeaux 4-2 pour auxerre
auxerre c'est une bonne équipe également
il avait notamment fait jouer kasparov
il ya quelques années dans leur équipe
donc ils sont toujours capables ils ont
gardé un effectif correct mais auxerre
n'est malheureusement pas une ville de
tradition africaine dont il n'y a pas
beaucoup de ces rois dans l'équipe alors
ensuite une grosse écrit cross équipe
très grosse équipe can can qu'ils
rencontrent et nice et une bonne à une
bonne raclée quand même 5 1 pour cannes
à noter que nice et ont également une
belle équipe puisqu'il ya dans cette
équipe de nice yussif dorfman
d'intervalle recruter ni s'ils viennent
de montrer en première division et
d'hormones dans ce match perdu contre
eux etienne bat contre etienne bacrot
tout à fait dorfman qui avait été
l'entraîneur détiennent et qui a sorti
je crois qui a transposé sur une
anglaise dans une sorte de gambie
s'étaient organisés il s'est fait tout
simplement explosé dans cette partie il
a fait un bain co avec les blancs il a
donné un pion il ne l'a jamais revu tout
simplement il a dû donner la dame et il
a perdu
comme un enfant iossif dans cette partie
je crois que voilà ils tiennent à
réfuter la conception blanche monaco
orange 5 2 pour 5,2 pour monaco monaco
qui est vraiment une équipe
impressionnante cette année monaco oui
c'est une assez grosse équipe
effectivement il ya quatre bons les
équipes on est limité on peut pas
prendre plus que enfin objet de faire
jouer quatre joueurs français et
féminine française
après il faut deux joueurs de la cee et
de joueurs étrangers donc monaco c'est
pas mal puisque je crois qu'il y avait
ce week-end si je me trompe pas puisque
dont je fais partie l'équipe de monaco
mais je me rappelle plus très bien il y
avait morose et beach ça c'est sûr
michael adams michael adams 0 pickett et
le petit dernier
je sais plus qui s'était rochard
miralles marc sanderson a oui anderson
voilà ulf andersen le très sympathique
joueur suédois donc monaco effectivement
lui j'ai mis 9 g amis puisque la
féminine a également grandement
également m donc ronde de rang 2 2
drancy bordeaux 5 2 pour bordeaux ouais
auxerre montpellier 4 2 4 2 pour auxerre
donc ça c'est une surprise puisque
montpellier une très grosse équipe
austère un peu moins bonne à noter dans
ce match la composition de l'équipe de
montpellier a été donné en retard ce
qu'ils ont fait et on leur a enlevé du
temps à la pendule donc les jours devant
pauline avec une demie-heure d'or fin
avril avait une heure et demie une
demi-heure de monde et l'a donc une
maintenant une rencontre très attendue
monaco cannes monaco cannes avec un
match choc entre alexandre mots croisés
beach et quatre chefs morose et beach
qui a battu qui a battu quatre chefs
deuxième échiquier etienne bacrot quand
michael adams a donc c'était vraiment la
rencontre phare de 7e ronde en force et
a permis à etienne bacrot de jouer
contre michael adams qui est quand même
qui fait partie du top 5 mondial
et en plus il a fait nul avec les noirs
donc ça c'est très très bonne
performance avec 7 bat station donc 2 0
pour monaco 2e rep a perdu une partie on
a joué solide tout simplement très belle
prestation
ensuite donc deux équipes nice orange
3,3 donc un match très tendu pourtant
nice était favori mais résultat nul
enfin ronde 3 sur la poule b auxerre
drancy 2 2 bordeaux montpellier 5 2 pour
montpellier ce qui n'est pas une grosse
surprise can orange 4 1 pour cannes ce
n'est pas non plus une grande surprise
puisqu'il était largement favori et
enfin monaco nice 7 0 pour monaco
oui cette héroïne nice avait pas mis une
très grosse équipe en face ils avaient
sorti tout leur fort joueurs ils ont mis
des joueurs locaux dont il y avait pas
de problème particulier pour monaco à
noter contre-performance de moi puisque
je n'ai fait que nul contre un joueur
pas trop fort mais sinon mon 7 0 on ne
peut pas faire beaucoup mieux
donc j'ai l'impression que comme monaco
monaco est grandes ambitions cette année
oui oui tout à fait monaco évidemment va
essayer d'être champion de france
ils n'ont jamais été encore donc on va
tout faire pour en gagner
bon bien écouter loi si tu veux bien on
va donner le classement maintenant vous
voyez de classement donc pour la poule à
clichy premier avec 9 points mulhouse
second vient ensuite nancy puis noyon
strasbourg gonfreville
cappelle-la-grande et enfin dernier
bijou villiers alors pour le classement
pour la poule b donc le classement c'est
bien entendu en premier monaco avec la
performance que vous avez réalisé c'est
quand même tout à fait extraordinaire
second auxerre suivi de montpellier 3e
can seulement quatrièmes ils ont pas eu
des matches faciles le pays ils ont
perdu contre monaco on vient ensuite
bordeaux orange drancy et nice pour
l'instant dernier
oui tout à fait donc enfin il reste
trois équipes en gros a totalisé 100 %
des points il s'agit de clichy mulhouse
et monaco n'ont clichés mulhouse vont se
rencontrer lors de la seconde phase le
prochain week-end pour les performances
individuelles on va enfin on va finir
avec ça en forme joël lautier etienne
bacrot qui font 2 points 2 sur 3 c'est
pas mal également
david marciano qui fait deux points et
demi
qu'est-ce qui a d'autres il y avait eu
christian bauer qui joue pas bien qui
fait un point sur trois donc sans bauer
en petite forme
laurent frayssinet un point et demi
c'est pas terrible jean-marc degraeve un
point et demi également igor nataf c'est
la grosse contre performance puisqu'il
ne fait qu un demi point sur les trois
parties arnaud hauchard fait un point et
demi
et là il ya toujours les clichois
olivier rooney qui fait 3 sur 3 marie se
bat qui fait 3 sur 3 les clichois
toujours très très fort en bas très
soudée donc voilà pour les performances
individuelles des joueurs français
nicolas c'est l'impression quand même
bon c'est vrai qu'ils gore a fait une
contre-performance mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il va revenir très fort
prochainement il est très très motivés
gore est peut-être un peu énervé donc
alors tout de suite on va arriver à la
partie quand même la partie quelques
heures de cette émission diagonale avec
une partie de la nationale 1 il s'agit
d'une particule sion petit laurent
frayssinet qui donc a s'est réveillé en
forme puisqu'il a perdu la partie
précédente contre anatoli visor et là il
jouait contre kevin sprague est
rappelons le qui était anciennement
candidat au titre mondial
donc il a joué des quarts de finale qui
est donc été dans les huit meilleurs
joueurs du monde
hélas le petit l'an freyssinet s'est
énervé et la massacrer avec les noirs
donc une très belle partie du petit
laurent donc nicolas tout de suite nous
allons commencer cette partie
keynes prague at-elle blanc joue le coup
un e 4 il joue toujours sa toute façon
c'est normal l'auront avec les noirs
jouent ces 5 il s'est récemment orienté
vers la nage d'orphan l'âge d'or c'est
donc des six des quatre cci ouverte
je comprends qu'elle hypron cavalli est
bien moins f6 et l'ex 3 et là je crois
qu'on a également une peut-être une
souriante mais je suis quand même une
variante intéressante
au lieu de sortir le cavalier en c3 une
variante peut-être également f3 oui
alors f3 s'est effectivement c'est une
autre possibilité dans cette position
c'est de jouer son coup de pied le coup
f2 f3 qui défend le centre avec l'option
f et qui permet donc de jouer ces deux
c4 voilà c'est ça pour entrer dans un
en bis dans un étau de ma roxy qui est
toujours pénible à jouer côté noir c'est
possible cependant on peut jouer
simplement g6 sur f3 ou alors le coup
kelly c6 donc transposant dans un
étonnement oxis sans problème le lava en
principal étant eux 5 avec des
complications mais bon les deux courses
en plus principalement on reconnaît qui
a laissé 3 est quand même le coup le
plus fort pour les blancs puljic a7 a6
ça c'est la nage dorff et l'a donc petit
coup mon normalement les coûts à la mode
on a eu l'occasion de commenter beaucoup
de partis dans des chorales c'est fou et
3 ol3 qui amène à peu près des positions
similaires et là kevin sprague est
toujours le couffo deux fous c'est cathy
ci serait une erreur non non pas du tout
fous ces cartes est tout à fait jouable
nicolas jusqu'ici ont poussé quatre
c'est on a envie pour le côté nord de
jouer b5 direct alors on peut on peut on
peut commenter ça effectivement fous ces
quatre donc là nicolas tu dis b5 four b3
et maintenant alors en fait c'est pas
une erreur puisque sur le coup b4 je
sais plus exactement comment on joue
mais il ya des solutions pour faire très
très mal je crois qu'on sacrifie
l'option de joker et des cinq dans cette
position un volume social n'est pas
vraiment en prison si jamais les les
noirs prennent le pion en quatre il ya
des coups peut-être comme dame f3 voilà
9 3 c'est terminé tout de suite on va le
nouvel commenté rapidement dame f3 qui
attaquent donc le cavalier henri iv et
qui menacent probablement des choses sur
f7 avec le et le fou et la dame n'a une
découverte d'une valise il ya la tour à
vide qui est en prise donc il faut dans
les ouvertures ne pas négliger le
développement des pièces c'est à dire
que sur à 6 pouces et quatre les noirs
ne doivent pas faire la faute d'avancée
frénétiquement leur tombait sous
prétexte de gagner un pion ça serait une
grave erreur x 2 laurent frayssinet joue
la structure avec eux cinq alors à noter
qu'ici normalement on préfère plutôt
jouer avec eux six saisons kasparov hd
ça pendant des années notamment contre
karpov au championnat du monde
laurent frayssinet lui choisi la
structure avec eux 5 parce que c'est
plus risqué que si ça alors
le problème de ce coup e5 oui tout à
fait c'est un peu plus risqué puisque on
donne tout de suite la caisse des 5
c'est à dire que cette case et nathan
est acquise pour les blancs qui peuvent
qui pourront amener provenant de
cavaliers dessus et donc en fait les
noirs vont essayer de compenser leur
faiblesse du plan des six par un jeu de
pièces c'est ça les noirs vont chercher
de l'activité à tout prix d'ailleurs
directement pour commencer dans cette
position il attaque le cavalier 4 avec
le pion à 5 dont qui commence par gagner
du temps ensuite ils vont sortir leur
pièce d'une façon bien précise
on va qu'on va voir puisque laurent l'a
fait ça c'est l'idée on donne
effectivement cette caste des 5
mais en contrepartie on a des pièces
très très active cavale et b3 alors
pourquoi pas cavalier f3 dans cette
position alors qu'elle menait croire
c'est également un coût possible nicolas
tout à fait ça serait mettre le cavalier
là mais dont l'inconvénient de se
pousser que ça bloque l'option f
l'avantagé de ce coup c'est que je ne
sais pas quels avantages de ce compte
justement d'accord donc en fait le plan
dans cette position pour les blancs ça
va se faire petit rock et puis d'essayer
de faire un levier avec f4 pour mettre
la pression sur le centre il ya deux
possibilités mais après qu'il y avait
trois on peut également envisager de
pousser le plonger puisque il sera
défendu et par le fonds et par la dame
donc ça c'est un plan pour ses pions
j'ai juste changé 5 chasser lecavalier 6
et ensuite revenir sur la caisse des 5
c'est une possibilité l'autre
possibilité c'est de jouer simplement à
kehl 4 qui est également une option tout
à fait valable donc en fait on veut
laisser l'action du fouet deux valables
pour éventuellement pour cette plongée
et déceptions f libre d'avancé notre jeu
va évidemment principalement se dérouler
avec les pions normalement à droite de
l'échiquier sur les droits qu'elle est 3
fois hausse est là laurent frayssinet
sort ses pièces de la façon la plus
standard possible yves roquet d'ailleurs
les docks en rock et la cabine ce parc
est fait un coût qui n'est pas
considérée comme très bon en tout cas un
coup qui a l'air peu ambitieux il joue
le coutour vin qui ne qui n'entrent
finalement dans le classement
ce que tout revient ça vient
à l'encontre de justement de ce qu'on
vient de dire puisque l'idée pour les
blancs étaient des temps de pousser f4
donc quelques l idée en fait cacher
derrière ce coup l'idée cacher derrière
ce coup alors c'est que kevin sprague
dans cette position je pense a envie de
jouer le cavalier sur la case des 5
il veut mettre la cavaille en d5 mais
pour ça il faut défendre le tuant quatre
puisque sinon ce pion se retrouverait
une emprise
il n'a pas envie de jouer f3 dans cette
position ça se comprend donc il trouve
quelque chose qui va lui permettre de
défendre le tueur de 400 à faiblir en
jouant le coup f2 f3 le coup de pions
donc il joue taurin avec une idée de
créer peut être une attaque de majorité
sur la dame
il faut mettre son cabinet en décembre
déjà donc sur vous au 6 il souffre f1 et
maintenant il est vraiment prêt pour y
aller puisque l'on voit que la torah des
champions en quatre voilà en fait l'idée
de deux cabines frégate l'oranje calais
b 17
là on voit quesnoy ont fait leur
formation idéale ils ont sorti lors de
fouilles sur des cases qui étaient les
bonnes cases lecalier temps 17 prêts à
l'est soit ans et 5 soit éventuellement
dans certains cas sur la case b6 bon
voilà qui est donc en fait plutôt bien
laurent ne ne varie pas ses plans en
fonction du
pour par contre par rapport aux tours
1-2 des blancs non c'est à dire que
l'asnl le coutour on est assez
inoffensif les noirs ont une bonne
formation pièce qui est celle qui vient
d'être effectué justement par laurent
donc il n'y a aucune raison de changer
quand les blancs ne font rien d'accord
ça paraît assez logique donc à aider 5
ça y est lié alors là quand tu y vas y
arriver en dessin qui a toujours
plusieurs possibilités si vous jouez un
âge d'or vous devez le savoir soit on le
prend et si on le prend avec quelle
pièce on prend soin le fou soit le
cavalier et soit on le prend pas laurent
je pense à juste titre a décidé
d'éliminer la bête ce qu'on fait quand
même dans 80% des cas puisque un
cavalier comme ça en d5 faut pas le
laisser là il n'y est dangereux
je crois que le problème aussi c'est le
l'échangé éventuelle du fou qui est en
hausse est et je crois qu'il faut pas le
donner ce genre de fou alors ça dépend
c'est possible on peut donner
normalement les noirs peuvent donner des
fous dans cette position soit le foot
cases blanches soif ou 4 noir avec des
effets divers et variés mais ne faut pas
avoir de tabou faut pas avoir d'idées
préconçues dans cette position jamais
j'aurais donné mon full web et peut-être
peut-être qu'il faut le faire dès fois
en tout cas normalement on pense
cavaliers et si on peut alors ça c'est
la règle si on peut jouer cavalier prend
cavaliers c'est mieux que des foules en
cavalier c'est à dire que là laurent
effectivement il ya aucun inconvénient
prend du cavalier puisqu'après plus on
prend le fou en russie s'est attaquée
mais il a une case des fois il n'en a
pas donc là il vient sur les cases f5
est ce qu'on peut dire pour l'instant
que kevin sprague est bien
bien que son plan se déroule sans
anicroche puisque finalement c'est ce
qu'ils voulaient faire et ça s'est
déroulé comme prévu
donc c'est une préparation pour
l'instant qui a l'air de plutôt bien se
passer pour lui enfin il
il a dépensé énormément de temps pour
mettre un cavalier en d5 ce que
normalement ils leur arrivent à faire
assez facilement donc laurent frayssinet
n'a rien fait contre parce que j'imagine
pour sortir un coup comme tout revin il
a dû être une préparation à domicile
non non c'est tourcoing c'est un coin
très standard ça existe et très solide
après tout les blancs n'ont pas fait de
faiblesse qui ne regrettait pas
forcément très ambitieux dans cette
partie il était tendu décontracté il
vient là pour jouer il veut une position
jouable donc il joue quelque chose de il
n'y a pas trop théorie veut pas se le
faire planter dans la théorie donc il
était il était cool dans cette partie
kevin hin je l'appelle kevin parce que
les canadiens y parle français
donc on a sympathisé à 4 alors qu'elle
quel est le but à 4 passes et de nicolas
effective tout simplement empêcher le
cuir noir d'avancé en bessin qui est ce
que les blancs menace akata cinq ans
fait pour créer un trou en v6 oui ça se
fait on connaître le pion à 5
l'idée est pas vraiment de créer un trou
imbéciles c'est plutôt de fixer un peu
les pions noirs mais normalement ça se
fait pas trop de jouer à 4 à 5
en tout cas ça fixe mal les pions tour
s'est vite
laurent d'ailleurs s'en fout enfin ils
menacent corruption c'est du aulas est
une menace directe or s'est vite ces
trois défenses tout à fait direct
également et ça c'est 1,5 ou jugé que je
ne comprends pas en fait puisque les
blancs une majorité ll dame
pourquoi pas essayer de faire parler
cette majorité et de pourquoi pas
pousser ses 4 alors ces quatre nicolas
c'est pas pas forcément terrible on va
quand même y venir on va montrer ce coup
c'est s'inspire pas une pleine confiance
parce que les noirs pourraient jouer
probablement
je pense à 5 + b 6 ça c'est une
possibilité
je sais pas s'il le jour est à pour
empêcher en fait de l'est pour empêcher
la manoeuvre cavaliers d2d blanc suivi
de b4 c'est ça on veut paralyser
complètement la structure d'options des
blancs monts l'autre possibilité c'est
de jouer comme ce que laurent a fait
dans la partie ce qui a refusé ça ne
pourrait changer le mauvais fou me fous
qui est situé derrière étions m'enfin on
va pas trop s'attarder là dessus puisque
le finish de cette partie est superbe
donc on va on va avancer fou g5 fou
prend fou d'un prend donc la laurent
échanger son mauvais fou puisque le
mauvais fond rappelle c'est celui qui
est placé derrière les pions et qui est
sur la même couleur que les pions donc
là en l'occurrence pour les noirs
c'était le foot cases noires à 5
là le plan et pas seulement de fixer des
pions enfin et c'est pas vraiment ça
c'est plutôt de passer cette tour sera
la 4ème angers qui on le voit dans cette
position est dégagé
c'est la seule travers ce qui ne l'a pas
d'occupants donc on veulent occuper ou
g6 laurent in à son plan il veut
maintenant jouer f5 peut-être f4
peut-être f3 ou peut-être
4 enfin il ya une majorité de son oui il
compte bien avancer c'est ce qui est un
peu surprenante cette position on voit
bien le plan des noirs qui qui veulent
donc
tout balancer sur sur les droits par
contre je comprends pas le troll et
quels sont les plans côté blanc puisque
logiquement quand quelqu'un attaque sur
une aile l'autre partie c'est de contre
attaquer sur le trail mais là je ne vois
pas le jeu que les blancs peuvent avoir
sur les dames c'est tout le problème de
la position des blancs c'est vraiment le
problème c'est qu'ils sont très en
retard c'est pas qu'ils n'ont pas de jeu
le jeu on va le trouver on va pousser le
pion c'est après on va pousser le pion b
et puis ensuite on va jouer ces cinq
trophées du jeu ce n'est pas un problème
pour les banques
le problème c'est que pour organiser ça
ça va demander très très longtemps alors
que les noirs eux sont aussi aime
beaucoup du match sans déchets qui sont
déjà insuffisants déjà occupé le terrain
ah oui les noirs sont très très bien
placé donc tour à 4 joué par kevin sera
guette f5 normal laurent il y va il
fonce peut-être avec l'idée fkt f3 c'est
vrai que ça a l'air pas mal peut-être
avec l'idée de 4 et qui avait dit aux 5
c à l'air assez percutant également on a
vraiment l'impression que les noirs ont
rempli leurs objectifs
bon il y avait des faiblesses en d6 une
faiblesse qui est un peu moins apparente
maintenant mais surtout une très grande
activité de pièces très grande activité
de pièces
effectivement mon la la structure de
plus en plus les plus mauvaises depuis
qu'il ya le pion en d5 effectivement
l'option des six n'est plus menacée donc
l'année devant ont une grosse liberté de
jeu et ils vont bien en profiter
d'ailleurs on peut dire qu'à ce moment
là les noirs ont gagné la bataille de
l'ouverture oui tout à fait oui on peut
même le dire déjà depuis avant tours
bcap petite diversion attaque l'option b
cette menace de rentrée la tour sur la
7e il faut pas laisser faire ça défense
simple de laurent tour c7 est maintenant
kevin a peur du coup et 5 et 4 puisqu'il
sait plus quoi faire avec les blancs
alors le coup f5 f4 manager quelles
seraient les menaces
de d'un tel coup f3 f3 tout à fait on va
prendre un g2 on va prendre voilà
exactement
non ça il faut il faut pas qu'ils
finissent par gad trouve la défense il
joue beaucoup avec 4 alors justement ça
c'est effectivement sur le genre de
plans qu'on rencontre souvent dans ce
type de structure avec une tour en f1
oui bah oui c'est là qu'on voit tout le
problème de la position des blancs c'est
que en fait ils ont affaibli le roi
enfant tour c'est le roi blanc qui se
retrouve assez affaibli et l'a
d'ailleurs ça se
ça se paye c'est un jeu efficace on va
voir que le roi blanc a l'air en
sécurité mais en fait ne l'est pas tout
à fait rappelons une fois de plus le
grand principe de tarrach l'option bref
on avance toujours trop tôt et ça
affaiblit le roi c'est une catastrophe
si on prend 1,4 dam des deux pour contre
attaquer sur ce pion là laurent je me
fous f7 petite diversion il contre
attaque sur le point d 5 il a envie en
tout cas de d'éventuellement
contre-attaqué dessus mais c'est pas
grave
kevin prend en f4 t6 passe maintenant
sur fou prend des 5 on peut se dire la
tourette ans priscilla d'arbres reprend
le fou eh ben on va gagner la tour mais
il ya un échec intermédiaire c'est ça
tout à fait d'accord fou prend des cinq
le coup la fosse combinaison en fait 1
pour ainsi dire il ya d'un proche des 5
échec au roi donc la sacra échec mais
noir ne peuvent donc pas prendre la tour
non surtout pas qu'il doit donc c'est
terminé donc la foule prend des cinq ne
marche pas pour l'instant laurent
frayssinet joutes cavaliers 5 créant au
passage nicolas des idées de menaces des
années les menaces une case
il ya quelques casse
pour le cavalier désormais il a par
exemple il ya une faute on va la montre
est bon qui n'a aucune chance d'être
joué mais qu'il aurait pu l'être ces
cavaliers c1 qui provoquerait donc une
assez jolie combinaison cavaliers f3
échec
alors ça c'est assez marrant aya cavani
étant prise deux fois et par l'option et
parle à tous bon il fait échec au roi et
menacent de prendre la dame donc il faut
l'éliminer
on peut pas prendre avec l'option donc
ça on élimine puisque c'est un clouage
et si on prend la tour si la tour vient
prendre se câlinent la dame de reprendre
la dame
donc ça c'est bon c'est mignon c'est à
dire que là le cahier b3 défend la dame
c'est ce qui permet donc d'éviter ce
coup qui veut dire trois échecs donc
enfin c'est danser dans le vent ces
événements l'attak des noirs se déroule
c'est comme si la taille des noirs
commencent à devenir chaude le roi blanc
et est en péril et n'arrivera pas à s'en
sortir d'autant plus que la tour qui
étend ses sept maintenant on va bientôt
pouvoir se joindre au combat week-end
exceptionnel
elle protège en fait 17 à distance on va
pouvoir venir et en recettes et en 1/8
prendre la colonne eu qu'à une colonne
très importante
on remarque que le roi des noirs alors
lui n'a absolument pas à s'en faire il
est hors de danger
kevin stargate joue le coup j'ai 3
pourquoi et bien il a fait un plan
maintenant il veut défendre son pion des
5 pour pouvoir passer le cavalier de b3
à d4 et peut-être deux des quatre à six
ça c'est un très bon plan c'est à dire
qu'en fait la danse est stationné de
mettre le fond g2 est ensuite envoyé le
cavalier en d4 et en os 6 avec un très
très beau fou qui se rangeaient 2 donc
ça c'est un plan très très bon plan pour
les banques d'autant plus qu'à priori g3
ça va protéger plus le roi si on met le
fou devant ça s'est passé quand même une
valeur bizarre avoir joué le fou en deux
pôles remettre en f1 et puis le remettre
après angers 2 c'est vrai que les blancs
perdu beaucoup de temps quand même les
blancs perdre un maximum de temps c'est
l'inconvénient mais d'un autre côté il
n'avait pas fait beaucoup de faiblesses
lors on a très bien joué avec les noirs
laurent frayssinet très belle prestation
sur un âge d'or fisea tour eux cette
menace kf3 je crois que
je crois que c'est on peut le dire
puisque après kalyev trois échecs
si la tour vient prendre enfin le cap
des 3 ça libère deux choses la tour qui
attaquent la tour et la dame qui
attaquent la dame
donc une fois que la dame noire a pris
la dame blanche la tournoi verra prendre
la tour blanche
c'est une menace qui veut dire trois
chèques dont il en reste avec une
qualité de plus c'est ça une qualité
c'est une tour contre une pièce mineurs
câble yuv fou j'ai deux parents la
menace tour f18 réitérons la glace
décidément laurent frayssinet quand il a
une idée il en a pas deux et en fait là
il n'y a plus qu'une pièce un actif pour
les noirs c'est le fou qui est en fait
le fou henri vii il ya une menace
directe c'est encore cavaliers aux cinq
ans avec trois échecs sweet tour en tour
donc là il force kevins mariette à se
défendre tout re f1 ça y est il a
complètement chasser les blancs de la
colonne eux maintenant il est un peu m
de la position mais là les blancs contre
attaque sur f5
oui effectivement il ya une menace alors
c'est très important à signaler
et d'ailleurs la parade de cette menace
est très jolie puisque laurent
frayssinet zuccarelli g4 en fait il s'en
moque oui c'est ça ma lampe à tout à
fait état ce qu il il apparaît la menace
de façon indirecte nicolas surtour
confions il ya maintenant d'un programme
cavaliers prendre et la fourchette
fourchette zoo fork kavvadias trois
attaques et la toile 5 et la toa fin
donc une tour va être perdus et la
position après et sans espoir pour les
mains complètement sans espoir donc
c'est une défense indirecte du périph 5
ce dernier coup de laurent frayssinet kg
4 fouet f3 coupant la communication
entre les deux tours j'ai jamais des
bons coups ça c'est pas une enseigne
très bonne nouvelle mais en l'occurrence
la menace était quand même de jouer
cavalier 3 et ensuite peut-être de
ramasser le fou j'ai deux si on prend ce
rejet de l'option des singles est faible
et ainsi de suite
déjà les blancs ici ne pense plus qu'à
colmater les brèches ils sont plus du
tout dans des perspectives d' attaque
mais quand son adhérence le fou qui
vient à eux deux qui revient en f1 qui
vais en g2 maintenant qui vient en
relève 3 c
les blancs se débattent en fait oui mais
il faut il faut pas regarder tous les
temps perdu il faut plutôt regarder la
position d'une façon géographique et
historique dans cette position la
situation impose aux blancs de bouger le
fou alors qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il
faut le faire oui gens le font cavalier
23 laurent frayssinet s'incruste dans la
position de lenche tour c'est un tout eu
saïd a trouvé une cible maintenant on
voit trois pièces qui attaquent la même
cible le pion des cinq donc l'adoption
étant prises il faut le défendre
le cavalier très très fort kelly est
très fort et en plus il est indélogeable
c'est affreux
ces quatre là joli coup de laurent
puisqu'on voit que kevin sprite voulait
mettre le cavalier en d4
il pense à replacer son pib 3 depuis le
début de la partie de kevin squires mais
la dame h6 parade indirecte une fois de
plus contre la menace qui n'en était pas
une
sur cahier des quatre maintenant je
crois nicolas qu'il ya le coup j'ai 5e
ah oui la tour n'a plus de gaz en
fermant la tour f 4 donc qui est attaqué
par le pion et là il n'y a plus de
défenses tout simplement on a vraiment
l'impression que laurent coupe coup
après coup créé de nouvelles menaces de
troubles de nouvelles ressources d'attac
avait baissé effectivement c'est en
train de se passer
il ne laisse aucune pièce blanche stable
sur des positions clés c'est à dire que
là ils chassent la tour qui est henri iv
la tour s'en va en d4 avant d'être
attaqué
c'est pas grave blanc en france mais il
joue quand même g5 et de demande en
blanc qu'est ce que vous faites
il attaque il y lance tout en fait là et
la sai kevins brigade trouve une idée et
le coup c4 c5
c'est le contre jeu qui est censé
commencer alors le contre-jour on le
voit ils menacent de prendre des six
d'envoyer la tour cn c7 peut-être ou
même d'avancer ses pions encore une fois
il commence à y avoir du contre je donc
là les noirs doivent être précises il
fait enfin parler sa majorité
c'est l'heure c'est l'heure de pousser
les pions et la très belle réaction de
laurent fourrage 5 x 5 il a sans pions
en d6 lille est champion en d6 il le
laisse en prise alors il ya une pointe
tactique et en même temps c'est
positionnement très correct de jouer ça
parce que quelle est l'idée de laurent
sedran essais tour 5 sur la case eux
deux alors pour ça il ya deux ans nuit
un lequel il y en a eu trois deuxièmes
ennuis le fouet et 3 qui défendrait
cette case donc dans un premier temps on
va voir ce qui se passe si kevin sprague
est je vous prends fou est possible et
après on prend
si on prend pions et bien dans cette
session d'une pointe tactique c'est
choquant même le pion menace d'attaquer
la tour qui est en 8es promotion
peut-être derrière
oui oui donc il faut que les noirs et
une combinaison tactique alors il ya
plusieurs possibilités dans cette
position nicolas
je crois que la plus efficace moins une
des plus efficaces c'est le coup
cavaliers f1 cavaliers f1 qui allie afin
attaque la dame
donc on doit prendre ce cavalier en f1
prenant le on le prend par exemple avec
la tour et maintenant ils à tours 5
en e2 attaque la dame et en notant
menace donc avec les deux pièces et
menace la prise d'une armure en échec et
mat
et là c'est imparable très fort cavalier
afin quelques jolis coups tf1 c'est
assez joli effectivement c'est mon petit
point de tactique mais qui n'est pas
vraiment surprenant dans la mesure où
toutes les pièces noires sont quand même
superbement placé donc c'est vrai qu'il
faut pas trop pensé sur l'historique des
coups mais quand même
le fou de cases blanches à à bouger 5 6
fois pour se faire échanger voyez
d'ailleurs alors il veut pas se faire
échanger il est persistant il revient en
h1 c'est effectivement ce fou après un
parcours long et pénible c'est vraiment
laborieux mais pour arriver sur une case
horrible donc bon c'est les coups les
coudes et blanc ont pas été
effectivement jouer au mieux née des
noirs ont effectivement très bien joué
qu'à valider un cc lors de l'invasion
attend pour cavani signe un lacet on
envahit complètement pourquoi mettre le
cap verdien c'est pour libérer
donc on voit que laurent frayssinet
petit à petit a libéré et la case demain
hélas cazaux 2 alors la case au dos il a
libéré en chassant fou et l'a quasiment
une coupe la tour mais quelle cavaliers
diabolique depuis le début ils créent
des menaces en f3 enlevé en f1 il est
dépassé par beaucoup de beaucoup
d'endroits surtout reprend cavaliers
puisque les blancs auraient pu le
prendre quand même à noter qu'après
foutront dame prend là momentanément les
blancs ont un fou un cavalier contre une
tour c'est à dire que les plus forts
mais malheureusement il ya toujours cinq
ans un échec qui ramassent la dame
puisque on attaque la dame en même temps
la tour est défendue par la tour donc
ici ça ne va pas tout simplement et en
reste avec une dame contre
avec une dame entre callie convient mais
tout s et sa dame et tour contre tout
refus cavaliers c'est à dire un gain
très probable avantages matériels étant
largement suffisant le roi blanc ayant
toujours faible c'était affreux
donc après qu'elle ait des 1 là on entre
plus trop comment kevin parent garde aux
défis de quelles ressources at il trouvé
le paraphe qui est bien encore un coup
de fouet nicolas fou j'ai deux foulées 2
pour pouvoir remettre le sida oui donc
là laurent frayssinet joue tour un échec
fouet f1 alors le football c'est
vraiment bouger tout à fait alors là
laurent frayssinet donc qui est très
technique
on appréciait recul très très vite
joufflu f3 créant une menace toulalan
pièces jouent toutes les pièces jouent
point noir c'est diabolique cette
mutation
c'est au rythme lent mais là c'est tout
simplement terminer en fait dans cette
dans cette variante on peut mentionner
le croupion temps décide par exemple qui
serait un coût neutre où les blancs se
disent il n'y a pas de menace je
continue mon attaque et bien là qu'est
ce qui s'passe nicolas il ya un math
forcé avec tourcoing fouet fin échec
donc il faut prendre avec le roi
damages trois échecs cuisants échecs
donc si sur wave 2 il y adam g de maths
une sorte de baiser de la mort puisque
la dame vient embrasser droit et selon
laurent d'application s'est terminée et
après roger 1 il ya toujours un échec
petite diversion une dame prend la dame
doit prendre et c'est en g2 que ça se
passe d'alger de maths
cette fois ci c'est vraiment réellement
le pur d'aisé de la mort puisque la dame
est la seule à contrôler toutes les
cases de fuite du roi c'est terminé donc
là c'est une menace de laurent
frayssinet bref wave 3 comprend a pressé
ses petites combinaisons que le fou
effectivement de cases blanches est très
important puisqu'il contrôle est
justement toutes ces cases là le foot
case blanche où il contrôle c'est vrai
qu'un fou en f3 c'est quand même c'est
comme une calamité pour le roi blanc
donc la menace c'est tout reprend fou il
faut le défendre h4 sa s'oppose à la
venue de la dame noire dans le camp et
on a l'impression que c'est l'une
derniers soubresauts avant l'acte final
c'est exactement ça ici il ya tout 8,2
donc on voit les quatre derniers coups
de laurent frayssinet il a rentré les
quatre pièces noires qu'on voit ici que
je vais vous montrer en verre qui sont
arrivés dans le camp des blancs tout
simplement cet affreux cette position
est incroyable il est arrivé de partout
donc là qu'est ce qui se passe le fouet
fin et klum et donc ne peut pas prendre
la tour c'est impossible
la dame noire enfin la dame blanche est
attaqué par la tour il ya une autre
menace qui est donc tour j'ai deux
échecs
suivi tour pamfou échec et mat puisque
le fou de jouer donc il ya des menaces
partout c'est pas vraiment une surprise
lensois si elle n'a pas besoin de saddam
dans cette position c'est vrai qu'elle
est coupée kevin a abandonné la non non
non il a continué encore quelques coups
pour recours est sûre quel courage
il a joué tout reprend cavaliers c'est à
dire bon là c'est un sacrifice de dame
de l'isle adam laurent prend la dame
tout reprend et après tu reproches 4
donc le bilan matériel ces dames contre
tours et cavaliers met donc à priori ça
peut être équilibré mais là ça ne l'est
pas du tout puisque le roi blanc est
encore dans le vent c'est à dire que la
menace est de prendre ici en g3 et la
dame qui viendra a cédé encore 1 at
quelque chose de semblable
et le problème c'est que tout est encore
ouvert et dans ce genre d'opposition la
reine se complaît à merveille
donc voilà donc bilan de cette partie
kevin sprague est apparu s'est replacé
son cavalier en b3 de la partie il a
bougé énormément de poids sont fous
nicolas effectivement comme tu l'a
signalé c'est je pense qu'on peut
qualifier ça de parties de modèles de la
nage de off quand les blancs jouent
quelque chose d'un peu léger un petit
peu qu'ils ont une ouverture qui
manquait peut-être un peu de tonus
je crois que
que notre ami québécois effectivement
fait pas près de rejouer peut-être le
plan avec tourer oui en tout cas pas
contre laurent frayssinet donc une très
très belle partie de laurent donc nous
félicitons évidemment pour cette partie
il sera avec nous pour la leçon de lundi
prochain donc de diagonale la leçon qui
sera notre prochaine émission
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de plus
nicolas peut-être quelques news
en vrac eux dans l'ordre très rapidement
on peut citer effectivement un match
entre short et eksi young donc si young
a gagné contre contre nigal shore donc
c'était des parties rapides de 25
minutes
et surprise comme seahawks et la
championne du monde féminin elle
battrait forme grand maître guy vial
short qui était quand même candidat à la
couronne en jouant contre garry kasparov
et donc effectivement que simone qui
l'emportent également une simultanée
gigantesque puisqu'on a nié alors
excusez-moi pour la présente pour
l'aviation jeux payants que j'suis ans
qui a joué contre 1004 personnes à lui
tout seul à lui tout seul c'est vraiment
possible
oui ça a pris ça lui a pris 26 d'heure
enfin bon ça c'est ce qu'on a lu on a on
n'a pas été vérifiée sur place en chine
donc auxilio nous refait une simultanée
contre 1000 joueurs également shirov qui
joue un match partie rapide contrôle et
micheline pour la fin de cette actualité
se déroule en ce moment et ce dès les
résultats la semaine prochaine
voilà donc nicolas merci d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci voir on
te reverra prochainement peut-être pour
la sortie du site de lits et chaque
libération et on vous donne rendez-vous
à la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
diagonale merci